deep underneath Transylvania is a huge
subterranean cavern where something very
strange is happening strange and totally
amazing it's hard to understate the
historical value of salt wars were
fought over it people found in entire
cities around it at one point it was
worth its weight in gold but today it's
commonplace and this these salt mines in
a weird place you're left with this huge
cavernous space that you're not sure
what to do with well in Transylvanian
Romania they decided to do something
incredible with their cell phone it
looks like this review welcome to Salina
turna
tourists enter the mine through a
centuries-old vertical shaft and as they
descend it's like they're going into
some sort of futuristic subterranean
world that had to be built after a great
apocalypse and restarting humanity
underground it has this kind of Blade
Runner mole people thing going on and
what do you find in this futuristic
landscape well at about a hundred and
forty feet below the surface you'll find
mini-golf ping pong basketball hoops
bowling there's a hundred-person
amphitheater in there you enter this
vast enormous space and at the bottom of
it there is a salt lake with an island
of salt pile up in the middle where you
can go and rent a rowboat and row out to
that little island and then next to that
there is a giant Ferris wheel that's lit
up and spinning and it's all happening
deep underground in Transylvania what
they've done is taken this mine and turn
it into a Museum of the history of
mining but really it's a sort of general
purpose theme park with all kinds of
amusements in it we should go why are we
not going subscribe here and watch more
videos here